sprechen wir aus aktuellem anlass über
die aktuellen zahlen in sachen corona
mit professor dirk brockmann physiker am
institut für biologie der humboldt
universität zu berlin und auch am
robert-koch-institut schönen guten tag
brockmann herr professor sie sind
experte für die modellierung also die
vorhersage der ausbreitung und dynamik
von infektionskrankheiten solche wie
corona auch für das robert-koch-institut
dann also jetzt gerne einblick in ihre
persönliche glaskugel wie geht es weiter
mit corona und uns ein
zunächst zeigt sich jetzt erst einmal
das was auch schon vor einigen wochen
eigentlich prognostiziert worden ist
dass wir sozusagen in die flanke der
dritten welle rein geöffnet haben und
dadurch die beschleunigung insbesondere
der b17 variante jetzt zu nimmt also wir
sehen jetzt ja zum beispiel fallzahlen
20 prozent höher als vor einer woche
es ist zu befürchten dass das jetzt
richtig an fahrt aufnimmt
die 117 das ist die britische variante
die macht laut robert koch institut
inzwischen etwa 50 prozent aller fälle
aus der aktuellen lagebericht und ja
auch ihre vorhersagen das rk ii sagen
dass nach ostern über 30.000 fälle pro
tag kommen könnten die institute könnte
dann auf 300 steigen im vergleich noch
mal für uns alle an weihnachten waren
wir bei etwa 32.000 der höchstwert lag
ende dezember bei fast 50.000 neuen
fällen wie kommen sie auf diese
vorhersagen naja das ist eigentlich ganz
einfach es gibt verschiedene modelle die
das tatsächlich simulieren aber man muss
eigentlich nur die export das
exponentielle wachstum also das
beschleunigte wachstum der b17 variante
fortsetzen dann kommt man auf diese
zahlen und es erinnert an die situation
vor der zweiten welle als gesagt worden
ist von expertinnen und experten
wir werden 20.000 fälle pro tag haben
und das war zu der zeit völlig
unrealistischen wir sind jetzt in einer
ähnlichen situation nur dass wir halt
mit noch höheren fallzahlen rechnen
müssen wenn nichts geschieht können ihre
modelle falsch sein
absolut natürlich können modelle falsch
seien aber man sieht das ja nicht nur an
den modellen sondern eben auch an den
vergleichen mit anderen ländern und
eigentlich ist die mechanik der
infektionskrankheit der pandemie
eigentlich eine einfache wenn es
genügend kontakte gibt wenn diese dieser
erwert größer ist als einst dann führt
das zwangsläufig zu einem exponentiellen
wachstum
das kann natürlich auch geschehen dass
irgendetwas passiert was diese
reproduktions zahl wieder unter diesen
kritischen wert rückt aber das kann nur
sein dass kontakte wieder reduziert
werden
verstehe ich sie richtig dass ohne aus
ihrer sicht ohne einen weiteren lockdown
würde würden die zahlen steigen und
würde deutschland und das
gesundheitssystem aus ihrer sicht ein
problem bekommen
das ist auf jeden fall ein szenario aber
wir müssen das auch regional
differenziert betrachten das ist etwas
was wir wirklich lernen müssen es gibt
gemeinden in deutschland die sind
praktisch instanz frei und an andere
gemeinden da ist die inzidenz sehr sehr
viel höher man muss das differenzierter
betrachten und dass das fehlt momentan
in der analyse also man muss genauer
hinschauen schneller reagieren und
genauer hinschauen machen wir doch mal
genauer hinschauen die berliner
amtsärzte hand zusammen mit anderen vor
einigen wochen gefordert lockerungen
nicht nur von incidents werten abhängig
zu machen wie ich sie jetzt aber gerade
verstehen sondern mehr auch tatsächlich
auf infektionsprävention und anderes zu
setzen
auf der internetseite der deutschen
physikalischen gesellschaft beschreiben
sie wenn sie nicht physiker geworden
wären dann könnten sie humanmediziner
nicht zeigen wo der hammer hängt ich
zitiere das haben die amtsärzte also
keine ahnung oder es sind instanzen das
einzige was zählt nein dass es da haben
sie natürlich recht dass instanzen als
eine zahl nicht betrachtet werden kann
wir müssen aber die dynamik dieser der
inzidenz der fallzahlen auf der
hospitalisierung betrachten also wie die
veränderung mit der zeit ist aus der
zeit veränderung kann man halt sehr viel
ablesen und genau das wird ja
letztendlich auch gemacht wenn man die
zeitliche veränderung der w 11 7
variante betracht
dann kommt man eben auf diese auf diese
szenarien und aus dieser dynamik muss
man lernen und wie ich schon betont habe
man muss es geografisch differenzierter
betrachten also man kann
berlin nicht mit der uckermark
vergleichen und das muss man tun
manchmal gerne über die zwei letzten
punkte die sie jetzt eben noch mal
genannt haben also dass das eine also
erst noch mal für alle aus ihrer sicht
müssten die lockerungen zurückgenommen
werden bevor wir gleich auf die
regionalen unterschiede kommen ja das
ist auf jeden fall ein weg der gegangen
werden muss er wir müssen halt dafür
sorgen dass weil wir ja noch nicht
systematisch testen können
in schulen oder in betrieben also immer
hat man kann man kann öffnen muss das
aber mit einer sehr sehr ausgebreiteten
test strategie verbinden
dann lässt sich auch öffnen denn das
testen
das screening sozusagen mit es das kann
auch verhindern oder ist ein sehr
wertvolles werkzeug das haben
verschiedene studien gezeigt um
sozusagen symptomatische infektiöse
menschen zu identifizieren die sich dann
in quarantäne begeben können das
werkzeug muss halt parallel zu den
öffnungen eingesetzt werden weil eben
noch nicht weil noch nicht so viele test
institutionalisiert sind bisher das
zweite was sie gesagt habe ist dann muss
man aber auch unterschiedlich gucken
nach den regionen also mit geringerer
incidents oder denen mit höherer
verstehe ich sie richtig dass man eben
dann doch sagen könnte die eine
geringere inzidenz ist da dürfte man
mehr lockern der dürften im zweifel
geschäfte eröffnet die mithörer eben
müssten dann härter angepackt werden er
stellt sie sich das so vor sie haben
zehn gemeinden eine gemeinde hat eine
instanz von 1000 und neun gemeinden
haben eine instanz von 0 dann haben die
im durchschnitt eine instanz von 100 was
sehr hoch ist aber in den neuen
gemeinden wo die inzidenz 0 ist kann ich
natürlich öffnen zum beispiel schulen
begleitet mit einer sehr sorgfältigen
test strategie so was geht gut habe ich
verstanden was sagen sie denen die sagen
es geht eben am ende nicht nur darum ob
die instanzen steigung nicht nur um die
patienten auf intensivstationen sondern
eben auch um das leben von uns allen
abseits also der das lockt downs also
der verband der kinderärzte
beispielsweise warnt vor noch mehr
vereinsamung depression aggressivität
gerade bei kindern wenn der lockdown
weitergeht die wirtschaft waren sowieso
schon lange vor einer pleitewelle viele
menschen könnten eben auch arbeitslos
werden wie spielt das aus ihrer sicht
auch eine rolle
natürlich spielt das eine rolle das muss
man immer mit rheinfaktor ihren das ist
ja keine keine wahl zwischen zwischen
gut und schlecht sondern dass es eine
wahl zwischen geringeren übeln und wir
müssen einfach dafür sorgen dass auch in
einer situation wo immer noch einige
hundert menschen jeden tag sterben an
kowitz dass wir das in den griff kriegen
und wir und andere expertinnen und
experten haben ja schon gesagt wir
müssen halt in ein niedriges zinsniveau
wir müssen das geografisch lokal
differenzierter betrachten und dann kann
man auch schon sehr viel lösen auch die
test strategie muss ausgebreitet werden
weil ja mit den test dann wenn leute
negativ getestet sind dann können sie
sich auch viel freier bewegen das muss
man halt systematisch ausrollen aber
eher grund hier immer von das ist doch
das was die bundesregierung eigentlich
zumindest versucht mit mehr tests zu
arbeiten mehr zu impfen und trotzdem
klappt das offenbar so nicht
was ist dann die strategie na ja das
muss man ja also momentan sehe ich das
noch nicht dass systematisch in schulen
getestet wird das muss ja auch aufgebaut
werden so etwas aber wenn ich mit dem
auto losfahren
dann lege ich vorher den anschnallgurt
an und fahren dann erst los wir müssen
halt zusehen dass die infektion
runtergehen lokal differenziert das
angucken und gleichzeitig wenn eine gute
test strategie und infrastruktur
existiert dann kann man auch öffnen und
zwar lokal differenziert das ist so ist
das halt und das ist natürlich auch
schwierig für alle alle sind pandemie
müde alle können nicht mehr
und dennoch ist die situation wie sie
ist dass wir mit einer b mit einer hoch
ansteckenden b 11 7 variante zu kämpfen
haben und dafür sorgen müssen dass
weniger menschen an dieser krankheit
sterben
dieses kind ist wahrscheinlich dann wenn
ich sie richtig verstehe schon in den
brunnen gefallen weil man eben aus ihrer
sicht geöffnet hat ohne all diese
voraussetzungen zu schaffen wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe und jetzt kommt auch
noch der stopp der impfung von
astrazeneca dazu ist dieser stopp so wie
wir ihn jetzt gestern auch in
deutschland
erlebt haben sinnvoll das ist schwer zu
beurteilen das muss jetzt erst einmal
herausgefunden werden ob da ein kausaler
zusammenhang besteht ich habe mir nur
die zahlen angeguckt wenn man in
deutschland sieht sind es sechs bis
sieben fälle von 1,7 millionen das
bedeutet von diesen hirn venenthrombosen
etwa zehn prozent dieser fälle verlaufen
tödlich das bedeutet eine person von
etwa 2 5 millionen menschen
die geimpft werden mit astrazeneca
können an dieser impfung sterben wenn
ich mir aber auch ansehen das von 25
millionen bürgerinnen und bürgern 2500
an cupid gestorben sind ist das halt
eine größenordnung vergleich den ich
mache und der mir sagt dass ich das
nicht wirklich verstehen kann wieso das
jetzt passiert man kann natürlich das
überprüfen man muss das untersuchen auch
aber man kann
ich bin jedenfalls davon überzeugt dass
man astrazeneca hätte weiterhelfen
müssen klare außer wer professor
brockmann zum ende dieses gesprächs muss
man vielleicht man ihr geschäft ist das
geschäft mit der vorhersage das ist per
se wissen wir ein kompliziertes die
glaskugel haben dann doch die wenigsten
von uns hätte man vielleicht nicht
einfach oder muss man vielleicht nicht
doch häufiger sagen dass ein stück wert
vieles eben auch ein treu und allen
versuchen und herausfinden ob es am ende
passt oder klappt ist und hätte das
vielleicht nicht auch ein stück weit
dazu beigetragen dass wir alle ein stück
weit auch generöser sind mit all dem was
die bundesregierung was experten wie sie
eben im zweifel sagen und was unser
aller leben eben betrifft dann auch
umgehen ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt wir sind in einer
ausnahmesituation die pandemie es etwas
neues gewesen sie ist etwas hoch
dynamisches gewesen sie kommt immer mit
überraschungen wie neuen varianten
das heißt man muss ganz viel trial and
error auch kombinieren mit dem wissen
aber was wir nicht machen können ist
dinge prozesse routine prozesse anwenden
in situationen die ausnahme und
notsituation sind und das passiert
meines erachtens manchmal und dann das
gehört einfach auch
mutige entscheidungen dazu auch dass man
hier und da falsche entscheidungen
trifft und da muss man aber dennoch nach
vorne sehen und aus den fehlern lernen
und dann bessere entscheidungen treffen
das gehört zu dem prozess dazu professor
ed portmann physiker am institut für
biologie der humboldt-universität und
epidemiologe am robert-koch-institut
hatte ihnen hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch bitteschön